All right.
Wow.
When you get back on the grid and you really get back on the grid,
we are alive for the second time today.
I am the guy on the show wearing the shirt of the show.
Uh,
get into that a little bit more,
just a second.
But I wanted to do just a live stream just directly with you guys.
It was great to sit down with Ben and I knew that was going to be fun.
I knew it was going to be kind of Cathartic.
I knew it was going to be a little nutty.
It was just going to be a little bit of everything.
Uh,
because after not ingesting the news since August 1st about 34 days a,
obviously I had missed a lot,
but I also had time personally to kind of work on some things I wanted to work
on,
clear out some space in my brain.
Uh,
there was a one week period,
so I actually,
the last week,
uh,
so all of last week before I got back on ended up being a work week.
I wasn't on my computer and I was in,
um,
you know,
I wasn't doing anything obviously on social media or emailing or that kind of
stuff.
Um,
but I was taking a couple of phone calls and we were doing a lot of work here
because as of today we launched a new website,
Dave rubin.com,
which we had been trying to get for tea at least 10 years,
maybe 15 years.
Uh,
there's Dave Rubin in the middle of the country somewhere who had this family
website,
but he slowly wasn't using it or he was using a less and less over the course of
a couple of years.
We're finally able to get that from him.
So we now have Dave rubin.com.
So all things Ruben report,
you can still go to Ruben report.com.
It's going to send you over to Dave rubin.com,
uh,
and all things Rubin report will be there.
You can find out more about the show.
You can also find out my live events.
I'm back into standup again.
I'm on tour with Peterson.
Actually.
I leave tomorrow morning,
uh,
to head out to Rochester tomorrow.
Then Long Island,
my home island,
uh,
on the sixth.
Then we're up in Connecticut.
Uh,
then on the eighth I'm doing an event in New York City with uh,
with Faisal and guitar.
He's been on the show and with Eric Weinstein and a couple other people,
I think Melissa Chen is hosting now in anyway,
there's just a ton of stuff going on.
It was just incredible to be away for a bit.
You know,
like I saw a couple of people on Twitter.
I actually only looking at my Twitter mentions once or twice today when I saw a
couple of people like,
oh,
how can you say you're like a newsperson or in the news or whatever and take
time off from all of this.
Like,
you know,
that's not possible.
And it's like,
actually I feel I feel more clearer on things now.
I sent like a little bit of clarity with some things and I think getting away
from the noise is,
is important,
is as important as being part of it all the time.
And I think everyone could use a little bit of an escape more.
I think part of the problem right now is that we have enough escaped.
So yeah,
so launch a new website.
We redid the set,
which was a tremendous amount of work.
So we wanted the set to look a little bit more like my,
uh,
my house itself.
We want it to be a little more,
a little more slim and trim a can.
We've jumped to the wide shot for a second.
Is that possible while we're doing this?
So,
uh,
we,
giving me a signal,
we can't do it.
Okay.
We can't do it.
That's all right.
All right,
well what we're gonna do is I'm going to talk a bit about Patriana in a second
and we'll do some behind the scenes video stuff on Patrion.
That'll a,
that'll show you that.
Um,
there we go.
We're going to do a picture.
Okay.
Uh,
yeah.
So we wanted to set just to fuel a little more,
uh,
a little more minimal.
I love the set that we had before.
We had it for about two years,
but it's good to just freshen things up.
So we've got new artwork on the wall.
The picture that is behind me and behind the guest are done by Kaitlyn rose.
Janet,
who's done a bunch of artwork for us and I have a lot of her art in my house.
Um,
these shelves right here,
I don't want to brag people.
All right.
You can bring it back to yeah,
either way.
Uh,
the shelves over there don't want to brag,
but they are from Ikea and I do have a bunch of them in my house.
Uh,
in the middle of the thing there.
we've got some of my old standup tapes from the late nineties.
We've got every book that is now on the set,
by the way,
is a book of a guest of the Rubin report.
We thought that was pretty cool before we had a mix of just some other people
who have influenced me and things.
Um,
we have new carpet,
new tables,
new chairs.
Um,
we changed some lighting things.
so basically it was just like a big reinvestment in all the things that we're
doing here.
I think it's good to just,
hey,
I think it's good to reinvest in things.
I think it's good visually just to mix things up.
And,
uh,
I think I just wanted,
I just felt like doing something fresh after taking a big,
a big break like this.
So new website,
a new set,
you may have noticed we have a new theme song.
So I found,
so one of the things I was doing when I was off the grid,
uh,
was I was listening to a lot of music and I've lately really,
really been into non vocal musics or just,
you know,
like music,
but no singing,
no words.
I get it.
You love a girl,
you lost the girl.
Okay.
It's all good.
Uh,
so I've really been into simply if lately,
which I really liked.
I always liked these sort of long melodic,
a sort of futuristic d but kind of eighties throwback music,
a interludes that,
you know,
the movie oblivion.
I really love the soundtrack Tron,
the movie.
I love the soundtrack.
Um,
Ho,
you know,
there's a bunch of this stuff out there.
Um,
so I was really into simply then I came across this guy,
marvel 83,
uh,
and I just loved everything.
The guy who was doing it was just while I was away.
It was just speaking to me,
the tenor of it,
the tone of it,
it felt like,
sort of real but also thoughtful and decent.
So there was a song by him,
which you can check out on youtube later,
uh,
called Venice beach.
And that was the song that I really wanted to be the theme song.
And we laid it in a couple of times.
We couldn't get it quite right.
Um,
so we ended up going with another song called every evening,
which I did just as much and he's kind of sampling his own song from that.
Uh,
and he's a great guy.
And,
uh,
we,
we chatted a bit.
He's in the Czech Republic.
Uh,
so marvel 83 if you're watching,
thank you for the,
for the song.
So we reinvested all that and as you can see,
the,
we have a new graphics package.
So the,
the video that you saw when we came in and the,
the lower thirds as we call them in the guest's name pop up and swipes and all
kinds of other stuff is all new.
But the real big thing.
And then I'll,
I'll take your questions and I'll talk a little bit more about,
uh,
being off the grid and that kind of stuff.
Uh,
the real big thing that we relaunched today was we relaunched our patriot and
now we got on Patrion in June,
I think of 2016 and I,
we were basically the first of these sort of political talk show things to be on
Patrion.
It was a lot of video game things.
It was a lot of um,
more anime stuff.
I don't know,
that kind of thing.
And we jumped in and,
and I've told the story before,
but the night before we launched and we had,
we had left our jobs at a TV.
We left our salaries and insurance and the whole thing.
I said to David and mirror,
I was like,
look,
this thing could go bus tomorrow.
Like maybe we really just screwed up.
And I don't think we did,
but we shall see.
And within hours of launching we realized that we were going to be okay on the
show has grown exponentially since then.
We've expanded the team.
We just had another higher actually over the summer,
which is thanks to you guys on Patrion.
So we just hired Helen who is now my assistant and assistant to the Rubin report
and she's just great and I'm sure uh,
you guys will meet her at some point as well.
And,
and we're still looking to expand beyond that and some graphics people and some
other things.
Um,
so the show is just grown and grown and grown and I'm really proud of what we've
built.
And what we realized though was we wanted to clean up Pedro cause we were in so
early that we did some things that maybe we wanted to do differently.
You guys know I do this day,
I do an 8:00 AM to 8:00 PM day once a month where I do these one on mostly one
on one chats with people who are the very high tier people.
And we realized that because I'm on tour with Jordan Peterson now,
and this is basically we're rolling into 2019 on this,
I'm about to do another like 50 stops with him,
16 in Europe,
which is all on Dave rubin.com.
I don't think the European stuff actually is there yet because we're finalizing,
I might miss one or two in the middle.
Um,
but uh,
we've got all our dates on there and stand up dates and all that.
But the point is we're,
we're expanding,
we're building everything we're doing and we felt that I was just,
I didn't have as much time to do the one on ones and we want it to change the
tiers.
So in many cases,
if you are on Patriot and you're one of our patrons,
you are now getting more for less.
We're going to try to make the livestreams and Ama is this kind of thing a
little bit bigger and more engaging.
But also one of the things that I really realized when,
when we were off the grid was that,
look,
everyone looked,
the Internet's great.
Social media,
it's all good.
You know,
we can complain about it all the time and obviously we all have issues with it
and people are seemingly acting crazy and behaviors online or re leaking into
real life and okay,
all that stuff.
Um,
but I do think that overall the conversations that are happening,
this is a net good.
I still think it's a net good.
Um,
but the trolls and the haters,
not even the trolls as much,
but just like haters and just all that stuff are just ran sacking everything.
They,
they're just like going through and destroying everything.
So our feeling was if we can build some real community on patrion where for,
you know,
a couple bucks you can get in and,
we post all our videos there,
you can chat with people who you might agree with my disagree with,
but do it in somewhat of a respectful manner.
And if you won't do that,
we'll just return your money and that's it.
We thought it would be a cool thing to do.
So that's why we launched Reuben select and we posted a video this morning all
about that.
So,
uh,
you know,
since we launched originally on Patrion,
as I said back in I think June of 2016 we really haven't done,
I think maybe one other time we did a real push for it.
Uh,
but we do want people to know about it today because by being on Patrion,
you guys have allowed me to say no.
I said no to at least three networks in the last three,
uh,
in the last year that wanted me to join and be part of things I've said no to
bigger money offers a whole series of other things because I'm controlling what
we do here.
And we've got a great small businesses and that,
as I said,
we're expanding on that really is because of you guys.
So a,
here's what we're gonna do.
So anyone,
if you go to patrion.com/rubin report right now,
anyone that donates any amount will get alive.
Shout out on the stream right now.
Uh,
I've got a handy iPad here with all sorts of questions and a bunch of other
things.
So Ruben report.com/patrion and a donate any amount right there.
And you're going to get a live shout out.
Um,
and then we are going to,
Oh,
I,
I'm sorry.
It's not any amount.
It's level one or above.
You'll understand it when you get there.
Level one or above.
I'm going to give you a shout and if I did any amount it would be completely
insane and I'd be screaming my head off for the next five hours.
So,
uh,
or if you increase up to level one,
um,
and then let's just see.
I want to get this all straight.
Okay.
If you join level five or above while I am alive.
All right.
Now I will Skype with you as a thank you after this show.
That's right.
I'm devoting the whole day to it today.
Uh,
and then I head back out on the road.
So if you donate to level five or above,
you're going to get a Skype one on one video.
Thank you from me to day.
I promise you that a couple of just came in and John and Ben,
thank you very much.
Um,
and if you,
so level one,
you're going to get a verbal shout out.
Level two.
Okay.
Why am I wearing this shirt?
So this was our original patrion exclusive tee shirt.
So only people who are at the,
the the t shirt level of patron for the last two years have this shirt.
It's kind of fun cause I see it out in the Peterson crowds.
Sometimes people have worn it,
um,
to,
to stand up shows and wherever else I've seen him at one or two on the street.
So I went at the mall the other day.
So if you donate,
but we're not using these shirts anymore because now our new patrion shirts are
Reuben select shirts.
So these are the old shirts.
We've got a bunch leftover.
So there's a limited amount because we're not going to be printing anymore of
them.
So if you donate now while I am live at level or level two or above,
you are going to get the original Rubin report.
Patrion tee shirt.
That's right.
We're going to send that to Ya.
Uh,
and uh,
the select members are that are getting the new t shirts.
That's at a,
at a higher level,
a shout out to Jack.
Okay.
All right.
So I want to make this a little bit about that kind of fundraising and,
and talking about that.
But I also want to answer your questions.
I know you guys have a lot of questions about,
about the off the grid thing and just catching up on everything and everything
else.
Um,
so let's go,
let's just start doing some stuff.
Uh,
and I'm going to go to patrion first though.
I will jump in on super chat as well.
Um,
when is Kanye west coming on the show?
I am pretty sure it's going to happen.
Like,
just give me a little time on it.
It's one of these things.
It's out there in the universe.
This guy operates in the universe.
We're going to make it happen at some point.
Um,
Yo Dave,
where do you get your shirts,
your dress shirts?
I think they're awesome.
So most of my dress shirts,
I'm hesitant to say it because then everyone's going to start wearing them and
then it won't look as cool.
Uh,
but most of my dress shirts are Ted Baker,
uh,
which you,
there are Ted Baker stores.
I think they're in a Nordstrom or,
or Bloomingdale's,
but I've got about five of those on rotation that I,
that I really do dig and I know people really like them but please don't wear
them all over the place cause then then it won't be special anymore.
And that's obviously very important.
Um,
Reuben always seems to come back on the grid around my birthday.
Nine five happy birthday to you.
Please interview Michael Notes.
I'd be happy to have Michael on the show.
I think there was some discussion about it before I got off the grid.
We'll,
we'll make it happen.
We've got some great shows coming up.
By the way.
I'm,
we've already booked out basically through October because of my travels are so
crazy.
We had to get ahead of the eight ball here,
our guests next week.
Uh,
probably is the biggest get we've ever had.
We've been in the works on this thing for Gosh,
a eight months or so.
We were supposed to have this person on in May and then there was a little
hiccup,
but next week it's probably our biggest get yet.
And I think sort of what will be viewed as a game changing interview.
So I'm super psyched about that.
As I said,
I had to Rochester tomorrow,
then Long Island and Connecticut.
Then I come home for that interview.
Then I head out to four different cities in Florida with Peterson.
Uh,
then I actually have a couple of days at,
at my parents' house.
Uh,
then I'm down in a grand rapids.
We're,
we're,
we're all over the place.
So a lot,
lots happening,
lots happening here.
Uh,
remember you're going to get a shout out.
If you join a level two or above,
you're going to get a shout out right now.
Like,
Jonathan,
you just got to shout out my friend.
Thank you very much.
And if you jump in and level five or above,
you're going to get a Skype.
Thank you from me right now.
And by the way,
the whole point of,
of creating Reuben select,
as I said,
not only do I want to create a community there where you can actually chat and
engage with and respond to people without just the endless noise.
Look,
that thing's always going to exist.
this is the beauty.
This is the catch 22 of the Internet,
right?
We,
we put all of these things out there or I don't know that we put them out there.
All of these things got out there,
Twitter,
Facebook,
myspace,
Friendster,
all of these social media things and we never knew exactly what we were doing
and we started being friends with our coworkers.
And then,
you know,
connecting with someone from 20 years ago who then you would never going to
connect with again after one connection and all of these things.
And it just became this like giant cacophony of craziness.
And I know how many of you care about these issues that we talked about on the
show just as much as I do.
And I think by creating a little home,
a little space for that,
and by throwing a couple of bucks in,
it's going to eliminate 99% of the haters.
I mean,
that's the irony.
The,
the anti to get in the game is so low because you can create a zillion burner
accounts on Twitter and just a million anonymous accounts and the bots have been
ramped up and all of that stuff,
uh,
that is ruining a lot of the goodness and it's making good people crazy.
So I really want it to try to create or at least foster,
uh,
an atmosphere where people would be able to have good conversations and my guys
will be in their furthering the conversations.
I'm going to jump in,
you know,
when I'm on the plane and I have time and I'll be checking in with you guys and
responding and all that good stuff.
And so the level five tier that we have on Reuben select now is the group Google
hangout.
So I used to be doing all these one on ones in a couple of groups.
We've expanded the group,
Google hangouts to a bunch of them.
I think there are a hundred slots total and we do groups of 20,
and then groups of 10 and groups of five,
depending on how much,
uh,
you donate.
And I have to tell you,
they have been amazing.
I mean,
the,
the last two years that I've been able to once a month talk to a group of you
guys from all over the world.
Sometimes I'm talking to people from Australia and Mexico and Japan and Brazil,
all in one group.
And people have gotten to know each other.
It's also helped me frame some of my ideas because when you talk to people all
over the world and they're every gender and sexuality and religion and all that,
and you go,
wow,
we're all kind of thinking about the same stuff.
It really makes you see how actually a small the world is and,
and,
and that we can all care or be concerned about the same things.
It's pretty great.
Molly,
welcome aboard.
Thank you very much.
Michael,
how you doing,
my friend?
Uh,
all right,
let's see.
Uh,
do you see any viable way back to civility for a political party that is called
the other side and it's 30% of voters Nazis.
So Ben and I touched on this a little bit earlier.
Um,
it's gonna be tough,
man.
There's a fly in here,
a fly has made its way into the new Reuben reports that,
um,
it's going to be very tough if you're,
if your strategy and your go to move is always to say that the other people do
this because they're racist.
It's hard to back out of that.
Right.
And this is where the Democrats find themselves.
It seems pretty clear to me after talking to Ben that there was no backing away
from that,
that if anything,
it's just gotten worse.
So I don't know how much worse it has to get.
I mean,
this is,
this is the million dollar question.
How much worse does this sort of collectivist leftist monster have to get before
it implodes?
Now,
look,
he could implode if they do really badly in the midterms.
It could start in,
but I don't want to talk about this only through an American lens because this
isn't an only an American phenomena I'm getting,
I'm getting messages from all sorts of people all over the world that are
dealing with this in their own countries.
Mexico,
for example,
just voted in a very left government.
So
yeah,
I don't know how you do it.
How do you,
how do you call someone a Nazi forever.
And then finally you wake up and you go,
oh,
well I guess you're not a Nazi.
I'm just an asshole.
Then you got to really turn the Lens on yourself,
which is,
which is a tough one.
But I do know this,
that for the last couple of months I've been on this tour where Peterson,
I've done all sorts of speaking events.
I've been back on tour,
doing stand up.
We've sold out every single show that I've done and I am meeting thousands and
thousands of great people out there and people who agree and disagree,
and I'll have it.
One of the shows we were in,
uh,
Seattle,
I brought Eric Weinstein on.
So what I tried to do at the standup shows is I usually do about an hour or a
stand up and then I bring on one of the IDW guys.
So I've brought on Eric Weinstein.
I brought on Bret Weinstein abroad on Christina Hoff summers.
We have special guests come into the show in Salt Lake City and,
and a whole bunch of others.
Um,
but in the audience I had,
there was a,
there was a black Magda hat wearing Trump supporter and I'm only mentioning his
race because people seem to,
if you look at the world through this Lens,
then this is important.
And this white guy who happened to have a shaved head,
so basically look like a skinhead and he was a,
he was a liberal,
right?
So these people are flipping the script and we kinda got into it and I was
playing with both of them in the crowd.
They got up in the middle of the show and hugged.
So I'm telling you there are great things happening out there in the media.
Doesn't want you to see it because they want to keep you in this endless fight
machine and,
and just these hate machine and all this other stuff.
Um,
but don't,
don't fall for it.
Just don't fall for it guys.
All right,
quick shout outs to Jeremy Thomas,
Noah,
he and Jacob Chevy and Beth.
Great names,
people,
all very short names.
Lot of one and two syllable people right there.
Okay.
We're going to need some vice spray in here.
I'm being attacked over here.
Um,
okay.
Here we go.
I'm going to jump back into a patrion.
Um,
yeah.
Is there any chance of an IDW summit in the future to bring together all the
thinkers?
Everyone has come to be drawn to while you guys collaborate?
Very frequently in everyone's schedules are packed.
It would be very exciting to bring together this group with their diverse fan
base is for a large forum discussion.
Um,
I can't say too much on this,
but there are a lot of discussions about that.
Um,
there discussions not among,
not only amongst ourselves but amongst a lot of representation.
We're trying to figure it out.
So also you gotta remember Jordan and I are now on tour basically through the
rest of 2018 and then we're going,
I think to Australia in 20,
in February of 2019 and then maybe one or two.
I think it's going to end officially in March.
Uh,
Sam's doing live shows again,
Ben just did a couple of live shows.
So there's like a tremendous amount to coordinate.
The beauty of this thing is we know it's all working.
Every single one of us that is doing this stuff is working and people are coming
out and spending their hard earned money to listen to people talk about ideas.
Uh,
and as I said before,
the shows with Jordan,
I,
those are the ones that I'm most familiar with.
Obviously they've,
they've just been a true joy.
I mean,
they've been a true joy.
A couple of protesters here and there,
and I kind,
I've walked out and I've talked to some of the protesters and whatever,
but we have to just coordinate a massive bunch of stuff and also figure out what
do we all want.
We all want and need different things.
Some of us have shows,
some of us are academics who are now caught on the outside of that,
Bret Weinstein and Heather hiding,
for example.
Um,
you know,
somebody like Eric Weinstein,
who's been sort of the,
the architect of this whole thing.
The guy's got a job.
He works at Tlo capital.
So we're trying to figure out how to figure out all of this and get all the
parts right.
And um,
you know,
one thing I can tell you for sure is there isn't a lot of ego management.
I know you'd think that maybe with all these,
these big names and fan bases or whatever that you'd have like a lot of that
kind of stuff.
There really hasn't been any of that.
We're trying to figure it out.
I know a bunch of you saw that picture when the bunch of us Rogan Peterson,
Sam,
Ben,
Eric,
me,
went out to dinner.
Um,
it's like we just had a freaking great time and we barely talked about politics.
We talk about psychedelics more than we talked about politics.
So,
so trust me,
we're,
we're working about on all these things.
Uh,
all right,
reminder level one,
if you go to Ruben report.com/patrion right now,
or Dave rubin.com/donate a,
you're going to get a verbal shout out.
If you jump in at level one or above level two or above,
we're going to send you the original Rubin report.
Patriotic tee shirt.
We've only got limited amounts of the left.
We are not making them anymore because they're going to be Reuben select tee
shirts right now.
So this tee shirt that I'm wearing can be yours,
paypal,
a level five or above.
Uh,
the,
I'm going to Skype you right after this.
We're going to shut down and I'll Skype you as a personal thank you.
I will gladly say hello.
We can talk one on one for a couple minutes.
Happy to do that.
Uh,
Steve,
welcome aboard and thank you very much.
Um,
what else did I want to tell you?
All right,
let's jump into questions for a second.
Um,
superchat loved the new set.
Keep up the good discussions.
That is the plan.
Um,
hey Dave,
I'm going to be at the Connecticut 12 rules for life event.
I was wondering if you're going to be opening or be part of that event.
Thanks so much.
Love the show.
A lot of people,
the good work,
I will be there.
So I opened up the show.
I do about 10 or 15 minutes to stand up.
I get everybody going and screaming and laughing.
Jordan comes on,
he does about an hour and a half.
As I've said before,
it's different every night.
It's,
it's,
it's been a true joy to watch and it's humbling as shit for somebody like me
because it's like,
man,
this guy changes it up.
He explores where his intellect wants to go.
I can see him weaving in and out of ideas and kind of pushing an idea further
one night and then really jumping the next night,
the Q and A's.
Then I jumped back in.
He does the hour and a half.
I jumped back in for about a half hour,
45 minutes of Q and a where I take some audience questions.
And that's,
to me,
that's my favorite part.
And I actually think the audience probably likes it the most because Jordan and
I get to play around.
I get to make them laugh,
make the audience after the audience loved seeing the guy left.
So you're going to absolutely have a ball.
Uh,
so,
uh,
look forward to that.
Um,
by the way,
if you've pledged at the a level five tier or above,
email contact@rubenreport.com with your Skype name so that we know we can grab
you on Skype after this.
Oh,
we're actually,
if you've pledged any of the things.
So if you've pledged a,
and I need your Skype name or if you pledge and we need your shirt size and
mailing address and all that contact@rubenreport.com.
Kevin,
how you doing man?
Thank you very much.
Welcome aboard.
Welcome back Dave.
Where did that red chair run off too?
Okay,
so we have all the,
so we were trying to figure out what to do.
So it was a,
it was a crazy month,
um,
of doing all this.
Like even though we were off the grid,
we busted our asses.
Special shout out to a mirror who coordinated all of this.
Uh,
David and I were away for a little bit and there was just like boxes being
delivered everyday and things being moved.
And you know,
it all looks so easy like when you guys see it,
but it really wasn't.
So basically the entire set then got moved into our control room and it was just
stacked up and you couldn't move anywhere.
So we're trying to figure out what to do with all the stuff because you know,
part of me is like,
you know,
we should,
I don't know what to do.
Like I wanted to put some of it in my house.
Like I liked the stuff.
I know a lot of people would want the red chair.
You know,
we have to have the green chairs where the guests set.
We've got the artwork that was behind me.
We've got the artwork that was behind the guests.
I think that maybe we're just going to just offer it to the highest bidder or or
not even to the highest bidder.
You know what,
this is what we'll do for now.
Let's just see if something that happens here.
I have no idea and I'm just doing this off the top of my head.
If you,
if you want to make an offer on any of this stuff,
just email us with what you want to offer.
We've got the right chair.
We've got the old table.
By the way,
we've got the chairs,
we've got some artwork.
Pick something that was on the old site.
Make us an offer.
If you don't have a lot of money,
you make a case.
Why we should just send you something.
I don't know.
Let,
let's just see what happens.
Let's just see,
uh,
what happens and maybe we'll send you guys some stuff.
I can't make any promises yet.
Let me just see what kind of response we get on that.
But that,
that sounds something like that.
Sounds Nice.
Um,
let's see.
uh,
thoughts on the war on,
in and out and thought on.
Eric Bauman's call for a boycott on the burger chain.
Literally as we were having lunch just now.
David said something about the war on,
in and out.
I'm a little unclear.
They donated some money.
Someone at in and out donate some money to a conservative cause I will be very
clear on this.
I don't know the exact details of the story yet.
In and out is delicious.
I get it.
Animal style.
And now because I'm doing the Paleo thing,
I do protein style,
which is no bun.
You just get it on the lettuce wrap.
It is absolutely delicious and much like Chick-fil-a,
I'm not going to stop eating it,
eating it because some hysterical person doesn't want me to eat it.
So that's all I can say about that.
Keegan,
welcome aboard Dave.
Welcome aboard.
Shawn,
welcome aboard.
Thank you guys.
Appreciate the support.
And remember when you're jumping in at that level one or above,
you now have access to all of our videos in the patrion feeds.
So if you're sick of what's going on,
on the youtube comment section or just fighting with people on Twitter,
if you spend a little more time there,
me and my team will be in there.
But more importantly than us,
you'll be able to interact with some other people who actually want to engage in
these ideas.
And I know that friendships have been formed over these things.
When we've done the,
uh,
the,
the group hangout things.
I've now I've,
I've become with some of these people also some of the one on one people and the
group people,
but I've been to dinner with some people.
We've done some business deals with some people I know people have done other
business deals with other people.
So we can actually create a secondary,
I'm not trying to replace Twitter,
I'm not trying to build a new internet or any of that,
but I think we can create a little bit of a home for some cool people who
actually want to engage ideas and be respectful and also meet other likeminded
people.
I think that's what we can create.
So it's pretty cool.
Brian,
welcome aboard Josh,
welcome aboard.
Thank you guys.
Uh,
remember level five or above.
I'm going to Skype with you right after this thing level two or above.
You're going to get the last few patrion shirts.
They're all being switched to Ruben's select.
After this,
we've got a couple more left and you're going again.
Did you see that?
I just whacked that fly like Mister Miyagi over here.
Gimme some chopsticks guys.
All right,
here we go.
Um,
thoughts on the loss of Austin Peterson.
Ah,
did he lose?
He lost him.
So I didn't even know that.
Uh,
uh,
like one of the only politicians I like trumped endorsed Republican in name
only.
Josh Holly also thoughts on Larry Shop,
Libertarians in lost cause district.
So first off,
I didn't know that I had any,
I guess I didn't even know that that election.
I guess it was the primary.
What was that?
What election was they was the republic.
No,
I get it.
Yeah,
I guess it was the Republican primary and Trump endorsed this other guy.
Hallie.
That's a shame.
I really like Austin.
We have a couple of disagreements.
Um,
but I think he's a decent guy who's in it for the right reasons.
And I,
and you,
you haven't seen the last time,
I promise you that.
Uh,
Larry Sharp I had on the show about two months ago.
Really liked the guy,
libertarian running for governor of New York.
I think he's got big ideas.
I think he's,
he's pretty fearless.
He's,
he's a good,
um,
advocate for the ideas of libertarianism and limited government.
Um,
so I hope he gets a good showing.
You know,
the second part of the questions was about,
um,
libertarians in lost cause districts.
You know,
nothing's always a lost cause.
And I know that argument.
There's always this argument that I now see more from the right,
but it flips every now and again.
So for example,
I'll tell you like,
it flipped,
like there used to be an argument that,
um,
Ralph Nader would hurt Democrats more because he was going to get more votes
from Al Gore than he would've got from George W.
Bush.
And that probably was true.
Uh,
but now that is flipped where it's like generally speaking,
Libertarians,
which is the only viable potential third party thing at the moment and far more
than the Green party,
they're going to siphon off more votes from Republicans and Democrats,
which Republicans than are like,
well,
Whoa,
forget the third party because we don't want to risk it.
I,
you know,
that's a,
that's a short term strategy that I understand.
But if you really want to change ideas over time,
you need to start getting some of these people involved.
So I don't know that we're not getting a libertarian or even a more classical
liberal presidential candidate,
certainly from the Democrats in the next,
you know,
for eight years.
But what you can do is you can start flipping little districts,
probably more so in the middle of the country where libertarian ideas I think
have a better route than say in big cities.
Um,
you can start flipping some of those and getting some more of those ideas out
there.
I mean,
look,
why is this show working?
Why do I get the amount of hate that I get?
It's because I've given a little room for these ideas to,
to grow.
So,
so it's pretty awesome.
Yon.
Welcome aboard at the a level one level.
Thank you very much my friend.
Uh,
at the level two level,
you're going to get a Reuben report,
tee shirt,
limited edition because they hate me in printed anymore at level five and above.
I'm going to Skype with you right after this thing.
Okay.
Let's see.
I got the meet and greet for Jordan Peterson in Westbury.
Will you be at that meet and greet as well?
So first off,
I'm super psyched for this show.
It's on September six.
That's my home towel.
Long as it's not a town,
but uh,
I grew up in long island.
I'm from Long Island.
I Love Long Island.
Uh,
grew up a couple of towns over.
Actually I will be at the show.
So the meet and greet situation.
So this is what they do at these,
um,
you pay a little bit extra,
I don't know the number off hand and you can meet Jordan.
He does a private talk.
It's often for about 30 or 40 people.
He answers a couple of extra questions.
You get a picture with them,
an autograph.
Um,
I was just going for this last three months.
I would just go out into the crowd after and I had talked to as many people as
possible and it was all good.
Um,
my guys and the promoters,
my agents and the promoters said it was just too much of a mess to have me doing
that.
Um,
and also because,
um,
I generally like to stay as late as everyone will make.
Uh,
you know,
I don't want anyone to walk out there and be like,
oh,
Ruben didn't say hi to me and all that.
So I'd be hanging around for a long time.
So we're actually doing a separate meet and greet for me.
So my meet and greet will be first then Jordan.
Some people are going to go to both,
some people are going to go to some,
um,
I don't know the website off the top of my head.
I think it's OMG vip.com/dave-ruben,
something like that.
Close enough slash Dave Rubin,
O m g vip.com/dave Ruben and you can buy tickets to the meet and greet for me.
I'll hang out and I'll sign autographs and take selfies and all that good stuff.
Um,
and usually Jordan and I,
we stay as long as we possibly can.
Uh,
so we didn't,
we haven't even really started promoting that yet cause I've been off the grid.
Uh,
but I'd love to meet you in Westbury if you want to come on,
come on down.
Uh,
Patriot.
Do you consider Majid Nawaz and Douglas Murray as part of the IDW?
Why?
As I've said from the beginning,
I don't know that it's for me specifically,
certainly,
but I don't know that,
I don't know who it's for to say who is really part of this a morphous thing,
but I certainly would consider those to have them.
Uh,
the both of those guys.
Part of it.
Look,
I think one of the things that you have to have if you're in this is you have to
have an,
a willingness to have difficult conversations.
Module is absolutely having that about reforming his own religion.
Douglas who certainly having that when it comes to dealing with immigration
specifically,
but,
but a slew of other issues for Douglas as well.
Um,
but I think you also have to be tried by fire a little bit.
Those guys had been through the hate machine.
Um,
I think that for whatever the differences are,
you know,
Douglas a is a gay conservative,
Majid is a liberal Muslim.
Again,
all these label things like we've,
we've put a pretty diverse group of people here together.
I love both of those guys.
We had a wonderful dinner at,
at Douglass's,
a house with his partner and,
and Jordan and his wife and,
and uh,
my gene and his wife.
Just a great dinner in London while back.
So these are good people.
Where is Emma?
You know,
I tweeted out a picture of Emma,
14 years old,
greatest dog alive,
uh,
that we were going to be in here and she left right before we started.
So if you want to send her in,
feel free.
But you know,
she's an old timer now.
Uh,
Marusha thank you very much.
Welcome aboard to Patrion.
Oh,
by the way,
guys,
please,
if you're watching this and you did what we do here,
please click the little bell on Youtube and make sure you're getting all
notifications.
I am still getting a slew of people telling me they are not getting our
notifications,
that are videos never show up in their feed.
Youtube keeps telling me basically that you people are idiots and you don't know
how to subscribe.
Uh,
we used to have a personal contact at Youtube.
Then that person said,
uh,
no,
I'm not going to do this anymore.
Basically,
I'm moving on to other things.
They didn't give us another person to talk to you.
They just gave us the form,
whatever it is,
what it is,
uh,
with youtube.
Um,
but please make sure notifications are on,
or I know people go weeks without seeing it.
Are People still get unsubscribed.
We looked at our,
our subscription thing today and it's like,
it jumps and then it lowers into jumps and it lowers and to keep growing.
But we know it should be growing a lot faster than it is,
although it's growing quite fast.
Um,
one other thing on Patrion by on a youtube,
by the way,
I just found out this this morning,
so that we posted,
I thought,
well,
I think what,
we're pretty,
some pretty great shows.
While we were gone,
we posted a colon,
new are,
uh,
we posted Katherine verbal saying we posted Jeffrey Tucker and we posted,
who was the other person.
Oh.
And,
and Dr Deborah Sill a pretty interesting diverse group of people.
Um,
the Deborah,
so full episode now she's a,
a,
a a sex researcher and we had a long ranging co conversation on gender and
equality and a series of things that got demonetized.
You know,
I think it has a couple of hundred thousand views and back it monetize.
So that's the type of thing,
that's exactly why we're on Patrion.
If we were relying on the,
on the youtube money,
even when it suddenly gets better and they monetize things raw,
you just don't know what the hell is going to happen here.
Um,
so patrion is our way of,
of sort of safely funding these things so that I'm relying on you guys,
which I guess ultimately that's not relying either.
Like anyone can come and go as they pleased,
that's fine,
but at least we're not only reliant on that.
Um,
so yeah,
still give verbal shout outs.
Welcome aboard,
Sean.
Thank you very much.
Um,
let's see.
Can the importance of protecting the values of Western civilization be
overstated?
No,
I don't think they can.
I think we don't talk about them enough and we don't explain why the values of
Western civilization of free speech and opening cruelly,
uh,
open inquiry and um,
and
education,
secular education and um,
and not giving too much power to any one person or government.
These things have all been huge parts of Western civilization.
These are the cornerstones of what I think will give the opportunity for the
most people to be free this freaking fly.
Um,
I need those chopsticks guys.
so I think we need to do a better sell job.
For some reason.
The West almost seems to be suffering from its own success where it's like
something becomes so successful that then it breeds sort of a next generation of
people who hate it because they don't know what real suffering is.
So when you hear all of these young people at colleges now who are,
you know,
they're literally at colleges,
wearing designer stuff all walking around with iPhones and Nike's and all of
this stuff telling you how oppressed they are.
They have no freaking idea what oppression is.
You know what I mean?
You're not oppressed for being gay in this country.
You're not oppressed for being black in this country.
You're not oppressed for being any minority.
We have welcomed more of all of these people to this place to make a better life
for themselves.
And in almost every case it's worked.
And if you don't believe me,
think about your grandparents right now.
You person watching this,
okay,
pause for a moment.
Think about your grandparents here.
I'll think about mine,
okay?
Do you have it better or worse than them?
And in almost every single case,
you're going to have it better.
And that is pretty freaking great.
And on top of all of the studies by a book that I have right over here that
Steven pinker has written about,
it's called the enlightenment.
Now talking about all of the trends that are,
that are positive in the world where there's less mass violence and genocide and
there's more trees being planted and all sorts of other things.
But it's very easy.
If you always go to the fear center of the brain,
you can get people believing all sorts of horrible things and that are,
the wheels are coming off all the time and got Western civilization is evil.
It doesn't mean it's perfect,
but nothing's perfect.
And the people who think they can eat engineer perfection almost always are the
people who engineered some horrible,
horrible thing.
Okay,
let's go,
uh,
how much money do you use when a video is demonetized?
It's almost impossible to say because a,
it depends obviously on the video views.
What I can tell you is this,
and this is,
this is rough and uh,
if one of my guys want to correct me,
but youtube basically pays out a $2 CPM.
So that's basically we get $2 per thousand views.
Um,
I can't remember off the top of my head if that's before they are 55% cut or
after.
Um,
but I think it's about $2 per thousand views.
So that's pretty much it.
So then you could extrapolate numbers after that point.
So it really depends.
But it also now I think has to do with watch time and a series of other factors.
So in a case like the Deborah,
so one,
um,
where I know I laughed,
I saw,
I definitely had at least 120,000 views or something like that and it probably
has more now.
Uh,
and it probably had a great watch time cause we,
I think we did about an hour or so and it was a really engaging conversation and
the watch times on this channel are extremely good.
Our watch times last month,
last I saw was something around 20 minutes of video.
That's almost unheard of on Youtube,
right?
People Watch things for two seconds and click away.
So you do get some benefits related to things like that for putting up quality
content that people are actually watching and engaging with.
Um,
so a video like that,
I'm not going to do all the math in my head,
but we definitely lost a couple hundred bucks,
maybe a thousand bucks on something like that.
And again,
youtube can do whatever it wants and it's on us,
as I discussed with Ben earlier,
to figure out if there's some alternatives.
I know there's a lot of discussions being had about that stuff,
but as we figure all that out in other way,
if you,
if you care about this stuff,
join us on Reuben select and there's a bunch of different tiers and depending on
what you want,
by the way you can get,
so this is the old Rubin report.
Sure you can,
there's a new Rubin report shirt.
We've got Ruben report mugs.
I autographed some stuff.
We've got the one on one hangouts.
Uh,
well no,
we don't have the one on.
Yeah,
it's anymore,
man.
We got the group hangouts,
which we've expanded to now a hundred slots.
We've got,
uh,
some behind the scenes stuff.
We're going to do some more live ama as a whole bunch of other stuff like that.
Uh,
all right.
Let me do a little,
a little radio reset for you guys right here.
So I'm doing a Little Ama back on the grid.
Uh,
it's good to be back in.
Nice to talk to you guys again.
Uh,
I,
so far I've stayed away from,
uh,
from all that,
whatever hate may be coming my way.
I'm not really paying attention to,
um,
just having a good day here with my team and,
and doing the live stream abandoned with you guys.
Uh,
but what we are doing here is I wanted to tell you guys about Ruben select,
which is our new patrion programs.
You can go to patrion.com/ruben report or Dave rubin.com/donate and depending on
what tier you jump into,
there's all sorts of different or awards.
And right now if you donate at level two or above,
we're going to send you this tee shirt level one or above.
I'm going to give you a verbal shout out right now and level five or above.
I'm going to Skype with you right after this.
Or if you're a current patriot and you just move up to one of those levels were
good to go.
All right,
let's see.
Uh,
this is a good one on superchat.
Imagine Trump didn't happen.
What are your criteria for electing the next president in 2024 are you leaning
more liberal,
conservative,
or hopeful that liberals,
Libertarians will pose a serious threat to the establishment?
Here's what I would love to see.
Let's just,
not even,
Trump doesn't even have to be part of this discussion for a second.
What I would love to see and what I think will happen post Trump,
whether it's post Trump in in two years or if he gets a second term,
is I think that the bulk of people who are still quiet now because they're sort
of afraid of being yelled at and they're afraid of the mob and they're afraid of
being attacked and all of those things.
I think most of these people are waking up and most of us are.
These people were good,
decent people.
We disagree on some stuff we,
we feel,
you know,
everyone feels like everything is the worst.
It's the worst it's ever been.
And the pickle,
political tenor is the worst it's ever been and it can't get worse.
We're not killing each other over politics yet it can get a lot worse.
Let's stop it from getting there.
But what I will happen is the outrage machine on both sides.
We'll eventually start crushing itself.
And I think we're seeing that on the left at the moment.
It'll start crushing itself and there will be an avenue for some decency.
So what I would love to see I,
this is the best situation.
And then I'll tell you what I,
what I think I would go for the best situation I think would be for a truly
principled conservative to run against a truly principle and liberal.
What you would have by that is you could have a real limited government
conservative who may be conservative on things like abortion and uh,
you know,
would be for death penalty in a,
and a bunch of other things versus a liberal,
I mean an old school liberals.
So I would say someone more from the classical liberal family who believes in,
there's some sense of limited government,
but that the government when done right,
can do good things.
And again,
this is where I talk about why I still consider myself a liberal instead of a
libertarian.
But I'm always happy to have that conversation and I get it.
I am very intrigued.
I love talking to libertarians and the endcaps caps about how to disassemble the
whole freaking thing.
I think that's a really fun intellectual exercise.
Where do you draw that line?
Where is it a point where you absolutely need the government that that's an
interesting intellectual exercise.
I think there is a chance that we will have lanes for some decent people to come
out of what feels like a real sort of crazy mess right now.
I would love to have that debate and I think we will get there.
I actually do if we don't just tear ourselves apart,
which I don't think we're going to do.
I know that's counter to what almost everyone is saying.
Um,
but I really think we can get to a place where having a real fight over these
ideas are real fight over policy.
Why is the death penalty right or wrong?
Why is,
why is abortion right or wrong or why is it in the federal government's interest
to even have an make it an issue?
Um,
Roe v Wade as a,
as a federal issue versus status.
You,
all of these things,
whatever side you're on,
we should be allowed to talk about these things.
And that's why it's very cool.
I think when we look at the amount of people that are watching the show,
watching Shapiro,
listening to Sam watching or listening to Rogan,
it's like there is a massive group of people growing and growing and growing
there.
Okay.
Hearing different ideas that are okay,
watching people debate ideas and argue over things and not hate each other.
And I think as these people,
and they're mostly young right now,
as they gain more power and they gained more influence and they have more of the
influential jobs may be in mainstream,
I think some good things are gonna happen.
So I'm very hopeful for that.
Um,
do I think ultimately a libertarian could pose a threat to the establishment?
I think of court.
Well,
of course the answer's yes.
Right?
Like if you gave me the greatest,
most charismatic,
really principled,
well thought out libertarian,
I think those ideas really could win out the day in,
in many,
many cases.
Especially now where there's such tumbled politically.
Um,
Gary Johnson obviously was not that guy.
And I hate throwing the guy under the bus cause I think he's a decent human
beings.
So I'm not throwing him under the bus.
I'm just saying,
I don't think he was that guy.
But if there was a really,
really clever,
smart,
energetic,
um,
photo Janet,
you know,
Libertarian,
no,
I'm not going to do it by the way people,
uh,
out there.
I think that that would pose a real threat.
And again,
it's like,
you know,
it's always,
people always say,
well,
do we want a,
we want a revolution,
Bernie.
I want a political revolution.
And it's like,
you know,
a revolution.
You could say political revolution because it sounds nicer.
But the more these people talk about revolutions,
think about it.
If you live in America right now,
do you want a revolution?
Is it that bad that you want to revolution?
Probably not.
It doesn't mean we can't make it better,
but it,
the,
the way we talk about these things is very dangerous.
This is still a freaking good place and I'm going to keep fighting to,
to make it better.
All right,
let's jump back to our,
give a couple shout outs here.
Steven Ryan,
Max.
Welcome aboard guys.
A level one or above,
you're going to get a verbal shout out level two or above the last few original
Patrion Rubin report shirts because we're going Reuben select shirts after this,
uh,
and level five or above.
I'm going to Skype with you right after patrion.com/ruben report and Rubin
report.com/donate.
And remember the,
the wider idea here is not only are you funding this show,
but I promise you,
once you download that Patriot App and look what's going on in the feed there
and see those conversations,
there'll be conversations that you want to be part of.
And it doesn't matter if you're anonymous or using your real name as long as
you're doing it kind of respectfully and decently.
And by the way,
if a massive amount of trolls decided to suddenly pay me to,
to ransack the place,
we'll,
we'll just boot him.
I don't want their money.
So I'm exercising,
I guess a little bit of control over over the,
the big thing,
the big monster that the Internet has come.
If you've joined at any level,
by the way,
and we're going to send you a tee shirt or if we're going to do a Skype with you
or anything,
uh,
email us,
contact that Rubin report.com and as long as I'm talking about that,
uh,
somebody asked before about the set,
if you want any of the old set stuff,
we're still trying to figure it out.
What to do.
Make me your best offer.
Make us a pitch.
Either a financial pitch or a,
I don't know.
Whatever the hell you are.
What,
tell me something.
Tell me something fun.
Contact Rubin,
report.com.
I doubt we're going to part with the red chair.
Uh,
cause I think we're keeping that for when I do bigger panels,
but we've got the two guest chairs,
we've got the table,
we've got some artwork and a bunch of other stuff.
I don't maybe make an offer.
Let's make,
make me an offer I can't refuse.
You know what I'm saying?
Okay.
Um,
here we go.
do,
um,
do you think all leftists agenda and I mean,
black lives matter or me too or Europe,
immigration is controlled centrally.
Uh,
it,
it can be something more than stupid people talking about equality,
I think,
you mean can't,
um,
I don't know.
I got into this a little bit with Ben.
Like all of these things these days,
it's like,
you know,
these Twitter campaigns to attack people and all these anonymous accounts that
kind of look the same and use the same language.
And it's like,
is there some central controlling of this?
And it's,
look,
I'll go down a conspiracy theory.
I'm happy to do that.
But,
uh,
as Carl Sagan said,
and as I quote,
often extraordinary claims require extraordinary evidence.
So I would need some actual evidence to see that there are really coordinated
centralized campaigns on all of these things.
I think there are some high level talks about all of this.
So there's no doubt that the BLM people are talking to the me two people and
they're talking to these people in that people.
And that there's a coordination of all of this stuff,
um,
at some level,
but I don't know that it all trickles down.
It's hard to,
it's hard to really understand.
I guess that's a little bit part of the problem,
but it's also weird how it seems to be happening in all these countries all at
the same time.
Uh,
you know,
fortunately I think,
America has one great leg up on the rest of the world,
which is,
um,
our first amendment,
our right to free speech.
And not to say other countries don't have free speech,
but it is so enshrined as the First Amendment,
the most important thing you can have is our ability to express ourselves.
And as long as we have that and the government doesn't take that away,
we can fight these bad forces.
It's what I'm doing every day and I suspect many of you are doing in your life.
Uh,
shout out to James and shout out to Luke.
Welcome aboard.
Um,
all right,
let's see.
Uh,
Dave,
how's Your Gaming Hobby with Collin going?
What are you enjoying?
Will you be streaming on twitch with friends?
So we've,
we've thought about maybe doing a s a twitch thing or a little more with video
games in general.
I think maybe I would do something like that just purely,
purely for fun.
Um,
as I've been traveling I haven't had as much time to be jumping in.
I do have an intent to switch cause one of you guys sent me one and a,
I've taken that on the road a little bit but I'm also trying to write,
I'm trying to read,
I'm also just occasionally trying to catch up on some sleep.
So like I'm a little bit like sort of between things.
My brother visited for a week and we played a ton of NBA live.
We were playing,
I was the uh,
the 91 trailblazers.
He was usually the 86 Celtics.
We split a couple games,
played,
played some Mario Kart with my nephew.
Um,
we played,
um,
what's that game that everybody was telling me to get?
Not Smash Brothers the game.
It's Sorta like contra on ps four.
You blow up a whole bunch of shit with eighties video game camp or eighties
movies,
characters bust,
Bang,
bust,
but not bang bus.
That's something else.
Um,
Bob,
uh,
somebody helped me with this.
Someone will throw it in the comment section.
You're a button,
you can be like Arnold Schwarzenegger and Sylvester Stallone and all these guys
and Chuck Norris and you're blowing stuff up and a boom bust,
bust,
bang,
boom,
something or something.
Um,
let's see.
All right,
I'll move on,
but somebody get me that way.
Yeah.
Um,
let's see.
Have any of the commenters you've hosted in formed or deeply impacted your
beliefs?
Um,
well look,
I've certainly been influenced by people and I try to keep an open mind and
really hear people.
I really do.
I think you,
most of you guys know that that first time I had Larry elder on when we were
discussing racism and he just beat me into a pulp.
Um,
I think you know,
that that was one of my wake up moments.
Obviously Larry has really affected me.
I would say this.
I would say that being on tour with Jordan,
it's,
it's been a privilege and it's been a life changing thing.
I mean look,
this is,
this guy is probably the top public intellectual we have in the world right now.
I don't think I'm exaggerating when I say that,
the most influential at least.
Um,
and as we go from sold out city to sold out city and I watch him as I said
before,
explore his own intellect,
challenge his own beliefs,
you know,
go away for a week.
So he could do these couple events with Sam Harris where they went at it
intellectually and then see how that changes the way Jordan talks about this or
that and does it all respectfully.
And how also he survived the hate machine and the awful articles and all of
that.
If anything,
they've all made him stronger.
I would say.
He's moved me a little bit on,
you know,
I bought,
I think I've always understood the archetypal stuff and the need for stories and
things like that.
He does bring it back to why he thinks the west basically needs those stories
through a religious prism to survive what's going on right now.
I think that's a,
that's a really interesting point that I've been thinking a lot about.
I thought about it a lot actually when I was away.
Um,
so these guys have all influenced me in different ways.
you know,
Eric Weinstein not only brilliant mind on economics and math and all that,
but there's such an empathy.
There is a human that I think I've,
I've taken some of that in.
Um,
look,
I get to sit with great,
incredible people that not only do I get to interview,
but many of whom have now become my friend.
It's,
it's awesome.
It's great.
And if you weren't effected by these people,
you know,
I said this at the end of the last show with Jordan before we took the break,
I was like,
you know,
it's,
you guys get to come here and be with him for two hours and experience this.
And I know how important it is for you guys.
Well,
I've been on tour with the guy for months and you know,
we have private time in the,
in the green room before,
and we talk about some of the things that we're struggling with or,
or thinking about or whatever it is.
And it's like,
man,
if you don't change after you do something like that,
I,
I don't know what would change you.
So the best I think I can do is keep,
keep exploring my own thoughts,
keep seeing where,
uh,
where the truth takes me.
All right,
Ruben,
report.com/donate we now are Reuben select where we're building a really great
community.
I'd love to get that number.
I'm not worried about the financial number.
What I would love to do is I think we have about 4,700 patrons.
I'd love,
I'd love to get that to a to 5,000 in pretty short order to really help build
out that community over there.
And I think,
uh,
you guys will really dig what,
what's going on over there.
We have a special feed.
So basically if you go to level one,
if you go to the $5 a month tier,
you'll have access to all of the bid.
Every video we post on youtube,
you'll have access to in the patrion feed.
And then you'll be able to interact with some more likeminded people without all
the,
all the craziness.
If you go to level one or above,
I'm going to give you a verbal shout out right now.
Level two or above.
You're going to get a tee shirt,
the classic as we call it,
Ruben report tee shirt that is no longer being produced and a level five or
above.
We're going to give you a Skype thank you.
Immediately after the livestream.
Okay.
Oh,
the video game people,
Bro.
Force.
I don't know what the hell I said.
Bang bus.
I knew it was something like that.
It's Bro Force,
not bang bus.
Okay.
Very good.
Um,
thoughts on a Reuben report,
movie night or Ruben report.
Book Club.
We're thinking about both of them and we almost included both,
both two different degrees in this new Reuben select a tier thing that we're
breaking down,
but we,
we bit off a tremendous amount this summer.
As I said,
we expanded the team with a new hires.
We built out the new set,
the new website,
Dave rubin.com.
Um,
just the new graphics,
new music.
It was like a whole slew of stuff.
Um,
so we didn't feel we could lay that out and have it done properly immediately,
but especially,
especially,
I love the movie night one,
the book ones great.
Uh,
the movie night.
I just think maybe it would be a little more fun and as a less of a lift for
people.
Um,
so just a little,
a little patience on that.
I think you guys know we've been pretty positive.
Uh,
we've been pretty good I should say about,
uh,
you know,
following through with the things that I talk about here.
So,
uh,
let's see.
Keep,
uh,
keep believing in us and we'll keep going.
Patron,
how do you discuss ideas without hatefulness turning the topic negative because
I'm losing people.
I considered friends over a rational question.
Okay.
I'm really glad you asked this.
I get asked this all the time.
Uh,
and I want to tell you a little insider,
something that happened to me during the break.
So I mentioned to you guys that I had a,
uh,
a very good friend,
lifelong friend,
uh,
that about a year ago,
um,
we met at a bar and he just went on a row.
We hadn't seen each other in awhile,
but he just went on a relentless assault about politics.
He Ma,
you know,
he's got a,
he's massively anti Trump.
He's a progressive lefty.
Okay,
fine.
That's no problem.
I have,
I was that and I have many friends that are still left,
these and all of that,
but he went on this,
what became a very personal attack to me.
At one point I paused him and I said,
do you think it's possible that I believe what I believe as much as you believe
what you believe?
And he looked me straight in the eye and said,
no,
and I thought,
this is crazy.
This is someone I know my entire life.
You're attacking life.
My very integrity.
Now after that,
we didn't talk for about eight months or so.
Um,
he sort of called me and left sort of a half a poly.
I actually paid the bill for both of us and I just walked out of the bar.
I've never done anything like that.
And I think you guys know,
this is not how I conduct conversations,
right?
So I wasn't,
I wasn't happy with it.
But,
um,
we,
we basically lost contact for about eight months over these last couple of
weeks,
uh,
had this little break here.
He and his wife came over for dinner and I,
in my mind,
I was thinking,
look,
if,
if he wants to go down that route again,
then even me,
even someone who,
who is willing to engage in all these ideas,
willing to talk to people I disagree with,
but I won't be,
I won't be personally insulted or personally attacked.
And I made it clear that I was off the grid anyway.
So we weren't going to talk about current events.
Um,
so we didn't,
we didn't talk about current events,
we didn't get into any of that stuff.
We just talked about kids and basketball and video games and whatever else there
is movies and whatever.
Um,
and,
and but my feeling was if it goes down that route,
well then I gotta end this.
Like I don't need a,
a friend in this case who is just going to personally attack me.
Like I'm not a,
I'm a decent human,
but I'm not a punching bag.
And I think that's how a lot of you guys feel too.
It's like you can keep making overtures to try to explain yourself.
You can keep saying,
well I believe this and this and this and that's different than you.
And the person goes,
well you're racist.
And you go,
well I haven't said anything racist.
You can only do that so many times when you have to have some self respect.
So I think this is a little bit different for everybody,
but it's a,
it's a really tough one,
right?
It's a really,
really tough one.
Where do you say,
well,
I cannot do this anymore or I need a break from this,
whether it's a,
a friend or a family member or something else.
Um,
I think the best thing that you can do is try consistently to be as human as you
can with them.
I,
it sort of sounds cliche,
like what does that really mean?
But it's like try always to really like look at them,
get close,
get clothes in there,
look at them and you got to tell me I'm a racist to my face because I believe in
states rights or whatever the hell it is.
And it's like their arguments have become really,
really thin and that's why they're so angry all the time.
I had one other quick thing.
We had another couple over here.
Uh,
and uh,
the,
the boyfriend who I'm less friendly with who was a,
again,
a big lefty,
but I'm happy to do our thing.
We got into it over politics and,
and he was really,
you know,
he's coming at me with a lot of it,
just general talking points in the left,
systemic racism,
all of these things.
And the Republicans are so mean and Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
And I kept coming back with good arguments,
good arguments,
good organs and it kept escalating and kept escalating.
And there was a moment where I knew I could go in for the kill and if I went in
for the kill,
either he was going to come around to,
he was going to wake up enough,
let's say,
or he was going to go crazy.
Like it was not,
the night would have been a blowout.
And because I was on this break and off the grid and everything else,
I just wasn't up for it.
So like all right,
when I had him there,
I let it go and then we'll continue that conversation.
So you got to figure out what works for you.
But I know it's not easy and it doesn't and it doesn't feel good to turn the
other cheek all the time.
And some point when you're getting abused long enough,
you got to speak up for yourself.
Um,
okay.
People.
Ruben,
report.com/patriot and I want to read off a couple more your names.
If you join in at level one,
I'm going to read your name right now.
Live.
Shout out for Ya.
Uh,
it's also,
uh,
Dave rubin.com/donate.
Uh,
if you jump in at level one or above a,
we're going to do a,
a,
a verbal shout out for you right here.
Level two or above.
You're getting their shirt a level five or above.
I'm going to give you a Skype.
Thank you right after this.
Uh,
okay.
Yeah,
you can go to Rubin,
report.com/donate and figure out what you want to do over there.
Okay.
Uh,
and also by the way on this,
uh,
on these livestreams,
then I'm going to keep doing,
we're always going to prioritize the patrion questions because so many things
fly in a that I'm going to give preference to the people who,
who are the,
who are the supporters,
uh,
so to speak.
Um,
let's see.
there is no utopia.
So in systems designed for societies,
we was,
we must always grade on the curve.
The United States is clearly on the top of that curve for benefits to mankind by
a large margin.
Is there any country that comes close?
So I basically agree with you here.
This is the line about all these people that want utopia ended up bringing us to
dystopia because they think if they can just manage everything with central
planning and big government,
that good people and good things will happen.
Well,
it rarely does when you keep giving power to some centralized thing that's above
you.
Okay?
So in terms of benefits to mankind,
by a large margin of the ad,
the United States has done more good.
Yes,
I know people love to dog about this or that and have we made mistakes and,
and gone to wrong wars.
And all of these in all countries have done terrible things.
And if you want to be part of the international community,
you're gonna make mistakes.
And we're going to have presidents that aren't going to be perfect and who are
going to do things that one half of the people don't like,
and that the other half of the people don't like in all of these things.
Um,
but I just fundamentally believe that the freedoms that we have in the United
States are our freedoms.
That if they were everywhere,
and I'm not saying we should nation state and force these freedoms on everyone,
but imagine if every country in the world,
if all people on this earth had the freedoms that you,
if you're watching this in the United States,
imagine if people everywhere had the exact freedoms that you have.
Why is it that when,
when we've done,
uh,
you know,
gigs in London or in Canada or in some other places,
people are starting to become more and more concerned about free speech because
they don't have the protecting the protections that we have.
So we've got,
we've got great things here and we shouldn't forget them.
And it doesn't mean you have to bow to the United States all the time.
It doesn't mean you have to say we're flawless and,
and all that.
Uh,
but it means that you have to respect what are our founding fathers built
because they built something pretty great that gives more power to you than the
people above you.
And don't just give that up because it sounds good or it's easy.
Uh,
shout out to Agnes.
Welcome aboard.
patrion.com/rubin report.
All right,
so I'm gonna go a little bit longer.
And then,
uh,
we,
we've obviously had a long day here.
I got early flight to Rochester and then we'll go from there.
Um,
let's see,
uh,
um,
Doo Doo,
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo,
Doo Doo.
The,
um,
what's the rational counter to the intellectually dishonest word police that
aggressively ignores context.
For example,
the monkey it up story or Connor dailies father comments from the 1980s.
So I don't know the second one as for the monkey it up story.
So I just heard about this with Ben and hour ago.
Obviously,
I didn't know the news until,
until that,
uh,
and the,
you should watch the video where I give a good explanation on this,
but look,
Howard Cosell as I mentioned,
was fired from,
I think it was CBS after being basically the biggest sports broadcaster in the
nation because he said something about a black football player monkeying around
or something.
And it turned out because the guy had jumped over somebody else while playing
football.
And it turned out that that's what he used to say about his grandkids as they
were like wrestling with each other.
He used to call the monkeys.
Was He racist?
Um,
you know,
did,
is there is sensitivity there perhaps?
Um,
but yes,
this intellectual dishonesty where we're like,
where were gerrymandering the truth?
Actually,
that's,
I guess what we're doing,
um,
is,
is terrible and someone should not be fired for a verbal gaffe.
Uh,
you know,
look,
it's up to a private company to do whatever they want to do.
Okay.
That's one thing.
But unless you have a history of racism or do something that is truly,
truly racist,
not just use a word in a way that someone else doesn't like it,
we're going to get to a place where everyone will be afraid to speak.
Actually,
that is one of the things that came up when I,
when I would see people at the hardware store,
at Starbucks or whatever for the past month and people would come up to me and
there has our hazard off the grid and Dah,
Dah.
Many people would tell me something like,
oh,
I wish I could,
uh,
you know,
just get off the grid.
I Guy,
I can't do it.
Whatever my job,
I don't know.
I mean,
everyone I think can do it for at least for a little time and maybe not for a
month.
Um,
but a lot of people were saying how they've really self selected out that
they're getting on Facebook much less.
They're tweeting much less.
They're checking newsfeeds less.
Look,
that's good in a,
in a short term,
at some level.
Because if it's,
if you're distracted by that or it's making you frustrated or giving you a
headache or giving you short term memory loss or all sorts of things.
Okay,
all good to,
to control that,
that's fine.
Where it becomes bad is when,
if all the good people start self selecting out,
then we got all the,
the bad people in the haters and the angry people that are running the whole
conversation.
Now we've got a problem there.
Again,
this is partly why we wanted to do this Reuben selecting because I think we can
start building some community around some of the right ideas.
So it's Ruben,
report.com/donate or patrion.com/ruben report.
Kirk,
thank you Mike.
Thank you.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Level five or above.
I'm going to Skype with you right after this level two or above,
you're going to get this Ruben report tee shirt,
which is not being printed anymore.
Level one or above verbal shout out right now.
We'll do,
we'll do maybe 10 or 15 minutes more here.
So get in some good questions here if you can.
Um,
so if Trump can avoid any major scandal and keeps us out of war,
what each,
what chance do you think?
Uh,
he has,
uh,
being reelected in 2020,
so I'm just catching up on some of the stuff that Ben enlightened me on that's
happened with Trump over the last little while with this Michael Cohen stuff.
And the rest of it,
I would say short of being impeached,
if the Democrats win the house by a landslide and then just impeached the guy
short of that,
if the Democrat path is to keep going down with the democratic socialist,
then I suspect Trump will be reelected.
I think that that fringe thing,
which seems like it's mainstream because the mainstream loves it,
but it's a fringe set of lefty ideas.
Um,
progressivism is not mainstream.
Most people do not buy into this.
Most people do not buy into identity politics.
Most people do not buy into big government.
Most people don't.
They want to live and let live and that's it.
And I think that the Republicans are better suited to carry that mantle.
They fail at it often and they fight,
you know,
they'll tell you about low taxes and low spending and then they never freaking
do it,
but they've got a little bit of a better insider track on that than the
Democrats.
If the Democrats decide to become a little more moderate,
find some old decent liberals,
find their JFK,
find there,
Daniel,
Patrick Moynihan,
etc. Then I think there's a chance,
but I don't think anyone,
well,
let's look at it this way.
I don't think anyone that voted for Trump in 2016 if the Democrats keep going
down that road is going to be like,
oh,
the Democrats are the better option than this.
Right?
If the economy is okay and we're not in an extra war and there's been no major
terror attack or something,
that's really a game changer that we can't figure out right this moment.
I don't think anyone that voted for Trump a link and go,
oh,
that,
that's much better.
I was wrong last time.
That's much better.
Now,
the issue will be is if,
if,
uh,
the Trump people are the Republicans or conservatives wherever,
if they're just,
if they're voters just don't come out because they're just depressed,
they're like,
oh,
we don't like Trump anymore.
We don't like this thing,
but we're just not going to vote.
And then the Democrats are really enthused.
Well,
the,
then that will happen.
So there's really no way to fully predict any of this.
Uh,
as I said to men,
you know,
these,
um,
off year elections,
the 2018 thing,
conventional wisdom is that there's going to be a massive blue wave.
Again,
I don't think that people who are generally conservative or old school,
liberal or libertarian are going to look at the Democratic alternative,
which we used to be a little more moderate,
but now has gone really left and go,
that's better than this.
Even if this thing is extremely imperfect and surrounded and mystery and all
sorts of weird things.
But if the people that like that don't vote well,
then,
then you just,
you just don't know.
All right guys,
about 10 minutes more.
patrion.com/ruben report or Ruben report.com/donate we're building up our
community on Ruben select,
which is our new patrion program.
And there's behind the scenes videos,
there's live ams,
there's these big group hangouts where I get to talk to small groups of 20 of
you at the same time or 10 of you or five of you depending on what level you
jump in at.
And I talked to people all over the world on video.
Everyone sees everybody.
It's real cool and fun and uh,
and really,
really great.
Uh,
so hopefully you guys will jump in on that if you,
if you just,
uh,
if you like these ideas and you want to throw in for what probably costs you one
beer a get in on it.
Um,
okay,
here we go.
Um,
uh,
what about NASCAR driver?
Conor Daly lost his sponsored cause saying his dad said before he was born.
So I haven't heard about this yet.
That sounds completely bananas,
but very much the sort of where we're at in,
uh,
in 2018 but that sounds completely insane.
Uh,
can you please have guests on about comic gate and Star Wars?
What are your thoughts on how these things are filled with identity politics?
People have asked me this a little bit before.
Look,
I last yet.
I just sucked.
I didn't want it to suck,
but there were so many sucky things in there that I can't even begin to.
Just real quick in terms of suckiness,
who the hell snuck?
You're not going to tell us really?
How is he not,
not Darth pledges,
just boring and lazy.
They way they kicked the can down with,
with,
uh,
raised parents.
Ridiculous purple haired.
Laura dern shouldn't have been in the movie.
That should have been admiral ackbar is an aging old,
uh,
admiral who doesn't have any ideas left.
That's what you're thinking the whole time.
And then at the last moment,
he does this amazing maneuver and blows up,
uh,
one of the star destroyers.
But instead you have this character that you just met that you don't care about
who's a big celebrity.
And it's like ackbar gets killed off camera.
Leah.
Uh,
there's no force in space.
Stupid.
Why did Luke project himself,
they're forced if he was going to die anyway,
not,
why not have the fight,
have the freaking fight and die,
pull an ob one and let yourself die at the last moment.
Uh,
so many stupid things.
The,
the,
the fricking gambling planet,
which was utterly pointless.
All that aside,
the identity politics part of it actually is quite annoying as well.
Um,
it seems as if the way they framed it as these are all white,
generally older but white men,
right.
That's what,
uh,
the first order is white men and they're fighting this diverse group of young
people who just want freedom.
And it's like we get it.
We get into it.
You're doing here just,
you know what though?
I loved force awakens and I think JJ can clean this thing up.
Um,
all right,
shout out to Leo all.
I am,
I am specifically told here not DiCaprio.
So,
uh,
I don't know where that guy is,
but uh,
thank you Leo.
All right.
Couple of minutes more level one,
if you jump on right now in the next couple minutes,
I'm going to give you a verbal shout out right now a level two.
We're going to give you the Rubin report shirt that is not being printed
anymore.
We only got a couple left level five.
We're going to give you a,
a level five or above.
I'm going to Skype with you and thank you right after this.
Okay.
Let's see here.
Um,
uh,
um,
what's your opinion on Peterson solution for in cells specifically regarding
forced monogamy?
So I think it's actually enforced monogamy,
not forced monogamy,
which is different.
Um,
forced monogamy would be mean actually forcing people to be monogamous
enforcement.
Origami is basically talking,
strengthening the ideas of marriage is basically what it means.
I know that's a hard for a lot of New York Times writers to grasp.
Um,
so I,
I would want to hear him fully extrapolated.
I've heard him talk about it a little bit.
He's talked about it on the tour a little bit.
Basically,
I think when people talk about insoles,
I want to get this totally right.
They're talking about sort of this group where they feel are young males who
often are into sort of video games who have just removed themselves from the
equation.
They,
they are getting their sexual needs met with porn.
Um,
they're not interacting with the opposite sex.
I wonder,
I guess actually you could probably be a gay in cell.
Is that,
is that a thing?
A gay,
so that,
that must be a thing too,
right?
Um,
but in effect you just sort of cutting yourself off from these personal
relationships,
um,
and just sort of living online,
uh,
something,
something to that effect.
Um,
yeah.
You know,
I think that Jordan's book,
I think 12 rules for life is a pretty good antidote to that.
The book is called,
you know,
the subtitle is an antidote to chaos.
And really what he's talking about there is get your life under control,
want to fix the world,
but guess what?
You can't do it if your room's not clean.
And that's just sort of a metaphor for some bigger things.
Go be the top lobster,
all of the,
all of those little funny catchphrases the guys using.
I'm actually have a much bigger meaning,
so I'd want to hear him talk about it specifically a little bit more before I
come in on his feelings about it.
Uh,
now GM,
thank you very much.
Welcome aboard A.
All right,
this'll be my last official pitch people.
So if you want in,
you've got five more minutes and I know you want in,
you want in get part B,
part of a same feed where people are talking about these ideas.
Rubin report.com/donate or patrion.com/rubin report.
We've got the feed there.
You can interact with people,
you can do it anonymously or not.
We're gonna,
we're gonna boot the haters.
I don't want their money.
You guys will be your,
your funding this show,
your funding,
our expansion.
Why are we were just able to hire some new people and Redo the set.
We didn't have to do this,
but you guys enable us to do things and get new graphics and get new music and
all of that stuff.
Uh,
you guys are the ones that absolutely enable us to do it.
And we got some slots open at the level five or above tiers where you can get in
the goop Google hangout.
I do this monthly,
I chat with you guys all over the world video chats,
we talked back and forth and all that good stuff.
Okay,
let's see.
Um,
uh,
what am I doing here?
Um,
uh,
man,
there's a lot of stuff here.
It's hard picking things.
Okay.
Um,
Rucka and malice stated they're both interested in a debate.
Would you host hosted objectivism verse anarchism?
So you're talking about Rocka Rocka Ali,
former guests to the Rubin report and I assume you're talking about Michael
Malice,
also former guests to the Rubin report.
They want to have a debate on objectivism verse anarchism.
That's kind of interesting cause obviously objectivism sort of,
oh,
is almost like a,
you could say a strain of libertarianism with sort of more of a,
um,
more of an ethos around morality.
Uh,
verse anarchism where malice is an anarchist.
Let me,
let me talk to the guys privately before I make any,
any promises here.
Let me just see what's going on.
I could,
for all I know,
I'm walking into saying they'd been at each other's throats and I'm going to
commit to it and then,
uh,
God only knows what's going to happen.
So we'll,
we'll see.
Uh,
oh,
I guess they agreed to have it online.
All right,
let,
let me see about it.
We're,
we're kind of booked at least through October right now,
but let me see about it.
Um,
okay.
Let's see.
Um,
oh,
this is interesting.
Our property based ideals,
libertarianism,
laissez faire,
cetera in need of an update because of the advent of products which don't fall
under laws of production software,
automated services,
et Cetera.
That's interesting because now we've got sort of these decentralized things and
these things that don't need constant more and more and more production.
And we're in,
you know,
look,
this is a little bit,
this is sort of ancillary really related to when people are yelling about $15
minimum wage.
What I always bring this back to,
and I've heard many economists talk about this,
is that we're going into a more automated economy.
So the more you say that the jobs that are the most disposable,
which are the jobs that generally have minimum wage,
the more you say we're gonna have to inflate those wages.
The more the companies,
and this is what any company would do,
this is what you would do if you owned a company.
You wouldn't look to cut costs,
and especially if you're now having this wage thing that's artificially not by
what you can pay,
but the government is coming in and saying,
you're going to have to pay more now you're seeing your profits go down.
You're going to try to figure out how do you,
how do you get that to go this way again?
Well,
how are you going to do it?
You're going to fire all your employees at Mcdonald's in order with iPads.
We see this happening with fast food joints already.
I've seen this happening at a whole bunch of,
you know,
I've been traveling all over the country.
I see this happening at all sorts of places now where you don't talk to people,
you just pressing buttons and then something you know.
Then one guy at the end hands you something,
but that guy can be replaced to,
and then there's one guy that probably fixes all the machines.
So I do think we have to,
we have to rethink,
we have to rethink almost everything.
We're,
we're at an interesting precipice in,
in human society right now.
And we have to rethink,
uh,
how we're interacting with each other.
How do we,
how do the,
is there goodness left in these crumbling institutions in a time now where
people don't trust mainstream media?
How it's now on you to figure out who to trust,
right?
I,
I assume some of you,
you watch this,
you,
you like what I'm talking about.
You liked the conversations I'm happening,
but I certainly shouldn't be the only person that you trust and you shouldn't be
getting all your only information for me.
I certainly hope that you don't.
Um,
so we have to explore all sorts of new things,
but that's why I'm so hopeful for everything right now.
It's like there's such hope.
There's such energy.
If you see,
you know,
I read all these articles and it's like comedy is dead.
And television is dead and there's nothing new or original.
It's like,
man,
we're such chaos right now.
Or,
or perceived chaos.
You can be creative.
Come to one of my standup shows,
see what's going on.
I'm barely doing a set.
I'd go up there with maybe five jokes and I'm fiddling with the crowd for an
hour and a half and people have a freaking ball and I have fun and it's live and
it's interactive and we people are heckling me and I'm heckle and back and it's
all good natured and fun and the same time people are right now stand up comedy
dead and is that standup comedy is dead.
It's that the ideas of leftism are dying in realtime and because so many comics
come from outline of thinking,
now they've moved over to whining about it because that's also a part of the
part and parcel of the whole thing.
Lance,
I want to give you a shout at all right people two minutes more.
Who's going to allow me,
uh,
Ruben report.com/donate or patrion.com/ruben report level one or above.
You're getting a verbal shout out.
Only two minutes left level two or above,
you're getting the Rubin report shirt not being produced anymore.
Level fiber above,
uh,
Skype immediately after this live stream.
Let's see.
Um,
uh,
would you ever considering hosting a mock debate between two ideological Lee
oppose guests who have to argue for the other side?
That would be interesting.
So this would be along the lines of something that a bunch of us have talked
about,
but Eric Weinstein was really big on the idea of really strong man in your
opponent that really if you want to have a true,
serious argument that you'd want to steal man,
your opponent's views,
not mock your opponent's views,
not personally attack your opponent.
And we see plenty of this out there and just doing anything for clicks or
anything you would really want to steal.
Man,
those views go this,
this set of ideas,
this bulleted list of ideas.
This right here in this box
is exactly what this person is saying.
I disagree with all of these things,
but this is what this person is saying.
Now you can attack their motives or any of that.
You say,
this is what they're saying,
and then you say,
here's how I disagree with it.
Now we pretty cool to actually have two people that disagree with things,
steel man,
each other's views and then argue against themselves.
That would be actually pretty cool.
Let me,
uh,
let me think it through.
I've obviously got a couple of people in the chamber that I think maybe could do
it.
Uh,
so that,
that would be pretty great.
Uh,
all right.
I'm going to say my goodbyes.
So if you're jumping in a Reuben portadat compensation patrion rubric,
more.com/donate or patrion.com/ruben report,
uh,
you got to do a quick,
um,
I think we're going to build a really great diverse community there.
I think you guys can see we've reinvested in the studio here.
We've got a,
a huge,
huge guest.
I think potentially our biggest guests ever next week,
which I'm,
I'm super psyched about.
Um,
you know where I'm going back out on tour with Peterson,
I'm hitting up all these standup clubs again,
we're trying to figure out how to build out some bigger IDW things.
I think there's some technological answers on some of the big questions you guys
have been asking for awhile.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm truly feeling more energized than ever.
It was great to be off the grid.
I today it was like when I woke up this morning,
I was not nervous,
but I was a little like,
ah,
here we go again.
Even though I love what I do.
Like I don't know that there's anyone that loves what they do more than I do,
but I was like,
Whoa,
here we go.
The monster is back.
Let's,
let's do it.
Uh,
I'm going to figure out personally out to how to manage that a little bit more.
I told Shapiro today,
you know,
he does a regular Shabbat where he's off the grid from Friday night,
usually to Saturday night.
He sometimes,
he said he extends that over the weekend.
I've been trying to do the weekend thing.
I'm going to try to do that a little bit more,
just manage all of this stuff because I really think that that one of the
reasons that you guys watch this is because I've provided you with a little
relief or reprieve the craziness.
And believe me,
I'm,
um,
it's good for you,
but it's good for me.
So let's,
let's keep building that together.
We're going to keep doing great shows here.
Do more stuff on the road,
as I said,
and uh,
and hopefully,
hopefully I will continue to grow as you've seen.
And I will,
I promise you that I will be,
I will be honest about my opinions and,
and thoughtful when I'm talking to people and curious and all of that good
stuff.
Uh,
if you pledged people,
email us@contactatrubenreport.com and we'll take care of it,
whether you're getting a t shirt or whether you're getting a Skype with me in a
few minutes,
which I'm happy to do a email us your t shirt size and your mailing address.
We'll get that shirt out to you immediately.
Oh,
Linda,
I think you're the last one.
Lindo welcome onboard Linda.
Um,
and also I mentioned it before,
I wasn't really thinking about it beforehand,
but we've got all the old set stuff,
so may make us an offer we can't refuse.
We'll figure it out.
We're gonna figure out what to do with some of this stuff.
Um,
you know,
and if you know,
who knows,
just send us an email,
contact every report.com.
We'll see what's what.
Um,
all right guys,
uh,
thanks.
It's been a great first day back.
I got a couple of hours now to,
to have dinner and get out of the studio and stretch the legs and then I'm off
to Rochester with Peterson tomorrow night.
Uh,
I will be in Westbury Long Island.
That's my hometown show on a Thursday night.
Then on Friday night I'm doing an event in New York City with Eric Weinstein and
Faisal Al Mutar and Melissa Chen,
uh,
which I'll tweet about and a little bit.
I saw they tweeted about it earlier.
Uh,
then I got a couple of days and then a bunch of shows in Florida.
Then I'm back here and I'm back here before that.
Got The big show that I just mentioned and a couple of shows in Florida,
and then we keep the beat going on.
We've got,
we've got tons of great guests coming up.
I'm,
I'm super psyched for a lot of this stuff we're going to be doing.
This is just the beginning.
We're at the beginning again,
so I thank you guys and if you haven't checked it out already,
uh,
do checkout Ruben,
report.com.
Check out the new Dave rubin.com and see what's gone on over there for,
for show dates and meet and greets and all that good stuff.
And thanks for watching.
And uh,
over and out.